aquí
termino la cumbre de la unión europea en
bruselas los temas de la agenda fueron
como abaratar los precios de la energía
en plena crisis y la migración
especialmente la salida al conflicto
jurídico con polonia por cuestionar las
bases del bloque comunitario hay
tensiones entre eeuu y china a por
taiwán beijing dijo que no hará
concesiones después de que el presidente
de la unión americana dijera este jueves
que está comprometido a defender la isla
asiática si es atacada y la comunidad
cinematográfica estadounidense se
solidariza con las víctimas del
accidente en un plato de hollywood el
actor alec baldwin le disparó por error
con una pistola supuestamente de
utilería a la directora de fotografía al
inah hatching y luego ella murió
bienvenidos a este nuevo informativo de
france 24 yo soy mere clara calle y es
un gusto saludarlos comencemos en
bélgica para actualizar la información
sobre la cumbre europea los 27 países
abordaron los desafíos que plantean la
protección de las fronteras exteriores y
en particular la crisis creada por
belarús así como la transición digital
del bloque previamente o hablamos con
nuestra corresponsal en bruselas esther
herrera ella nos contó cuáles fueron las
conclusiones de la reunión
buenas tardes la cumbre de líderes
europeos hace escasos minutos que ha
terminado aquí en bruselas en que uno de
los temas principales de la de hoy ha
sido la migración un asunto igual de
divisivo que el que se mantuvo ayer con
la situación derivada por la sentencia
del tribunal constitucional en polonia y
también el aumento de los precios de la
energía en la unión europea en todo caso
sobre la migración preocupar sobre cómo
actuar especialmente como comentabas
raúl sobre la situación en las fronteras
exteriores especialmente en los países
de lituania y polonia que son
colindantes con velar nos recordemos qué
este país está utilizando a migrantes
provenientes de afganistán siria e irak
los envía hasta la frontera con la unión
europea muchos mueren de frío o también
mueren de hambre en las fronteras de la
unión europea todo para presionar como
una represalia por las sanciones del
bloque que lleva manteniendo un pulso
con vela rusa desde hace casi un año
contra el régimen de alexandr lukashenko
finalmente los líderes europeos han
decidido aumentar esta presión estas
sanciones y aún así también se habla de
nuevas medidas se ha discutido la
situación de que siquiera se puede
aplicar un muro pero esto tiene requiere
dudas morales aún así la comisión
europea se ha comprometido a estudiar
qué medidas se pueden tomar para parar
esta presión también se estudia
sancionar a aerolíneas que envían a los
migrantes las fronteras exteriores de la
unión europea son cuestiones que se
deben estudiar aún porque la situación
de la migración preocupa mucho a todos
los países europeos en cualquier caso
todo esto se ha producido en la última
reunión de angela merkel como canciller
de alemania que ha recibido una ovación
y un regalo por estos 16 años siendo la
líder que más tiempo ha estado en este
edificio al consejo europeo los líderes
de israel y rusia se reunieron hoy es la
primera vez que el premier naftalí
bennett se encuentra con su homólogo
ruso vladimir putin desde que el israelí
asumió el cargo en junio se espera que
el tema central sea irán y el kremlin
también pidió mantener las buenas
relaciones especialmente en la
coordinación militar que han tenido los
países en siria la reunión entre p net y
putin coincide con el aniversario número
30 desde que las naciones restablecieron
su diplomacia
espero que a pesar de las batallas
políticas internas sobre las relaciones
ruso israelíes su gobierno siga una
política de continuidad en nuestras
relaciones con rusia son muy especiales
y en particular en estos días tan
simbólicos ya que estamos celebrando el
aniversario número 30 del
restablecimiento de estas relaciones
esta es una relación muy importante para
israel no solo por el pasado compartido
sino también por el presente y por el
futuro otra de las noticias en rusia es
que al menos 16 personas murieron en una
explosión en una fábrica de pólvora todo
ocurrió en la región de ryazan al
sureste de moscú el ministerio de
situaciones de emergencia dijo que el
estallido se produjo por una falla no
especifica durante el proceso de
producción de pólvora las autoridades
desplegaron a más de 170 socorristas y
50 vehículos para apagar el incendio que
se generó
y en francia el gobierno anunció un
subsidio de 100 euros para quienes ganen
menos de 2000 al mes y congeló el precio
de gas durante todo 2002 con el
propósito de contrarrestar el aumento de
los precios de la energía nuestra
periodista en parís natalia ruiz nos
amplió más temprano esta información
sí muy buenas tardes y feliz viernes
también para todos ustedes pues
efectivamente se esperaba que esta
semana el gobierno de manuel mac como en
algún momento dijera cuáles eran las
medidas que iba a tomar ante el alza y
ante él después de alta el alza del
precio de la gasolina y finalmente pues
pues son castex como bien lo decían
ustedes quién hizo este anuncio anoche
jueves durante el noticiero más visto
aquí en el país sin embargo no se fue
por esa idea de ese cheque digamos para
pagar el combustible sino en realidad
están buscando impactar a mucha más
población porque son 38 millones de
franceses los que van a recibir este
cheque de de 100 euros y además de esto
pues la idea es paliar también pues el
golpe que está alza de los precios
generalizada de los precios es decir de
la inflación pues está dando a los
bolsillo de los franceses en todo caso
pues estas ayudas como ustedes bien lo
decían si será serán para quienes ganen
menos de dos mil euros netos mensuales
pero además no solamente es para las
personas que tengan automóvil es decir
que estas ayudas van
y asalariados los empleados los
funcionarios pero también para los
estudiantes
becarios para las personas que están
buscando empleo e incluso también para
los jubilados este dinero debe irse des
embolsándose desembolsando a partir de
finales de diciembre y hasta más o menos
febrero de 2022 y como usted lo decía
pues este anuncio vino acompañado de ese
que el precio de el gas va a estar
bloqueado todo el año 2022 se había
dicho que iría solamente hasta abril
porque se espera que a partir de la
primavera comience a disminuir el precio
del gas ya que habrá pasado todo ese
período invernal todo esto pues en
realidad entre estas medidas que se
anunciaron una noche más el resto de
medidas que el gobierno ya ha anunciado
durante un mes por ejemplo con ese
cheque de energía y demás pues ya son 11
mil 500 millones de euros lo que le está
costando al gobierno nacional a ayudar
digamos a que los franceses no sufran
tanto toda esta inflación y alza el
precio de la energía y del gas en otras
noticias europeas ascendió a 7.000 la
cifra de personas que se han visto
obligadas a evacuar sus hogares debido
al avance de la lava del en cumbre vieja
el gobierno de las islas canarias la
comunidad a la que pertenece la isla
española de la palma anunció que
destinará más de 100 millones de dólares
del presupuesto de 2022 para la
reconstrucción a más de un mes del
inicio de las erupciones aún el volcán
se encuentra en actividad
y la otan tendrá un nuevo fondo dedicado
a la innovación militar uno de los
resultados de la reunión de los
ministros de defensa que comenzó ayer es
que firmaron un acuerdo para crear el
fondo de innovación inicialmente
invertirán mil millones de euros y su
primera estrategia será fortalecer la
inteligencia artificial el secretario
general de la organización jens
stoltenberg afirmó que espera que los
países fortalezcan su cooperación en
temas como las nuevas tecnologías de
defensa y el impacto del cambio
climático en la seguridad
y también en la reunión de la otan en
eeuu reafirmó una postura que elevó las
tensiones con china el ministro de
defensa de estadounidense joyce austin
afirmó que la casa blanca continuará
apoyando a taiwán para defenderse el
presidente estadounidense joe biden ya
había dicho que defendería a la isla si
beijing la ataca china por su parte
respondió advirtiéndole al gobierno
norteamericano que hablara con cautela
alva santana nos explica cómo están las
relaciones es una advertencia clara
dirigida a joe biden china no tiene
intención de hacer concesiones con el
tema de taiwán
eeuu debe actuar y hablar con cautela
sobre la cuestión de taiwán y abstenerse
de enviar señales erróneas a las fuerzas
separatistas de ese país y esto para
evitar dañar seriamente las relaciones
chino-estadounidenses
no se oponga a los 1400 millones de
chinos este mensaje llega después de que
el presidente vaivén dijera que su país
defendería taiwán en caso de que china
intentará hacerse con el control de la
isla autogobernada una declaración que
contradice la política exterior de eeuu
que ayuda a construir defensas en taiwán
prometer explícitamente su asistencia en
caso de guerra no obstante la casa
blanca aseguró más tarde que su postura
al respecto no ha cambiado china
considera a taiwán como territorio
nacional y ha prometido controlarla
algún día utilizando la fuerza si es
necesario con 23 millones de habitantes
taiwán es una de las democracias más
progresistas de asia y la presidenta de
chagin win ha rechazado la propuesta de
chipping de establecer el modelo de un
país con dos sistemas independientes
como en el caso de hong kong y macao su
negativa está enfadando a beijing que ha
intensificado las maniobras militares a
cerca de la isla haciendo volar aviones
de combate en el espacio aéreo de taiwán
y navegando con buques de guerra a su
alrededor desde el pasado mes de
septiembre se han realizado más de 800
vuelos y sobre lo que va de mes 170 otra
tensión entre estos países es por el
desarrollo de tecnología militar en el
indo-pacífico china criticó el pacto
aunque firmaron estados unidos reino
unido y australia para construir
submarinos de propulsión nuclear esta
semana los tres países defendieron las
negociaciones diciendo que no socavará
las alianzas asiáticas sin embargo
beijing respondió diciendo que august
amenaza la paz y la estabilidad de la
región china afirma que el desarrollo de
estos submarinos necesitará uranio
altamente enriquecido a más del 90% que
es el mismo que se utiliza para las
bombas nucleares pero también la
asociación de seguridad trilateral entre
eeuu reino unido y australia es un duro
recordatorio de que las reglas que
siguen los tres países siguen siendo las
reglas de la jungla donde los débiles
deben ser asesinados por los fuertes por
motivos geopolíticos y económicos
eeuu y reino unido- exportan submarinos
nucleares australia incluso a expensas
de violar el objeto y propósito del
tratado de no proliferación nuclear y
pasemos a otras noticias porque el mundo
del cine recibió con gran dolor la
noticia del accidente que causó la
muerte de la directora de fotografía
alina hutchins los hechos ocurrieron
durante el rodaje de la película rush en
nuevo mexico cuando el actor alec
baldwin disparó un arma de fogueo sobre
hatching la directora falleció en el
hospital en 2019 ella había sido
nombrada promesa de la industria por la
américa en cinematografía rosa pérez más
de uno cuáles fueron las reacciones
conmoción en hollywood por el fatal
accidente actores directores escritores
amigos compañeros lloran la muerte de la
directora de fotografía de 42 años alina
hatching las palabras solas no pueden
captar la pérdida de alguien tan querido
por la comunidad a efe y en a efe y nos
comprometemos a que halle na hatching
siga viviendo en el espíritu de todos
noticias absolutamente horribles y
devastadoras sobre la cinematografía
leena singh mi corazón está con su
familia no es el primer accidente mortal
de la industria lo recordó entre otros
mensajes la cuenta honorífica de twitter
del hijo de bruce lee brandon league
quien también murió en un contexto
parecido nuestros corazones están con
toda la familia deja lina hatching y
todos los involucrados en el incidente
en rust nadie debería morir por una
pistola en un rodaje nunca punto
tras algunas tragedias aumentaron las
normativas de seguridad del sector ahora
las autoridades investigan las
circunstancias en las que una pistola de
película causó una muerte real los
hechos ocurrieron este jueves en nuevo
mexico en el rodaje del western rast
cuando el actor alec baldwin descargó el
arma de utilería sobre la directora de
fotografía que murió en el hospital el
director del film joel souza también
resultó herido en el episodio mientras
que según testigos baldwin salió
devastado tras declarar en la oficina
del sheriff
en más noticias de américa el colombiano
mario palacios supuesto integrante del
comando acusado de asesinar al
presidente haitiano joven el moritz fue
detenido en jamaica la policía
jamaiquina no obstante no ha confirmado
este arresto el magnicidio fue cometido
por un comando de mercenarios que
irrumpieron en la presidencia en la
residencia presidencial en la madrugada
del 7 de julio sin hallar resistencia
por parte de los guardias de seguridad
y el presidente de brasil ya ir
bolsonaro respondió a las acusaciones
que le hizo el senado por su manejo de
la pandemia el mandatario dijo que los
cargos en su contra deben ignorarse es
que una comisión del congreso sugirió en
un informe acusarlo de nueve delitos
incluido el de haber cometido
supuestamente crímenes de lesa humanidad
los legisladores encontraron que las
decisiones políticas de bolsonaro
empeoraron la pandemia y contribuyeron a
que brasil fuera el segundo país del
mundo con más muertos por kobe 19 esto
fue lo que respondió el presidente
brasileño y
la gente que usa mentiras en el pasado
sigue mirando mi silla y sigue tratando
de sacarme de aquí en cualquier momento
con acusaciones fantasiosas como esta
audiencia de la pandemia que no ayudó en
nada simplemente le quitó tiempo a todos
los empleados dos días completos de
quiroga y funcional tomar todos y tecla
de dominio su quiero haga
y terminamos con una noticia religiosa
porque las oraciones del viernes se
reanudaron en irán después de haberse
suspendido durante 20 meses por la
pandemia miles de creyentes del islam se
reunieron en teherán y en otras ciudades
iraníes sólo que ahora se distanciaron
socialmente y portaron mascarillas en
este sermón semanal los altos miembros
del establecimiento clerical conservador
se unen besó a los viernes de oraciones
se da justo un día antes de que el país
reabra sus escuelas en medio de la
campaña de vacunación
con estas imágenes nos despedimos por
ahora pero continúen con más información
en france 24 y recuerden que pueden
profundizar la información internacional
en nuestra página web france24 puntocom
[Música]